America
is not a nation
uh-oh so the audio has now cut out
someone starts signaling him he's asking
which microphone is causing the problem
he's tapping his microphone he's wearing
a lapel mic and holding one he's
switching it on and off now he steps
forward it's getting awkward he's
talking into it but it's totally dead he
seemed to check his feet as if he had
like stepped on a cable and then now I
guess someone is going to maybe bring
him a different mic
okay now he's been handed a third
microphone this one's wired and it's
also not working he's talking into
multiple mics now and then he does he's
now he has the mic reversed almost about
to talk into the back end of the
microphone and then tapping the lapel
holding two mics and wearing a third one
this is unbelievable and now there's
cheering okay
and now he's back they were able to
survive the audio problems that's for
sure